Hello Freak bitches.
So let's talk about this rematch.
Which one?
Nate Diaz and Conor Mcgregor.
What are they fighting at 55 I do not know.
I don't think that's been solidified.
I believe that Connor is asked for it to take place at 70 which is where he was.
So he can say like,
I can do this exactly the same weight and then it won't be a factor,
you know?
But also I think he was really healthy at one 70 and I think you'd like it was
Connor.
I think you felt great leading up to the camp and leading up to the fight.
He just had a bad game plan and his ground Game Kinda got exposed to weight
classes above where you want to title two weight classes.
It's not true.
First of all,
they both weighed in almost exactly the same.
No two way classes above where he won his title.
Yes.
But not really.
All it is is they're not cutting weight.
It's too,
but he's not white.
Right.
But he's not fighting like Damien Maia who used to fight at two oh five or 185
and he's cutting down title shop and listen that title shots where it's like you
don't deserve title shot on two weight classes above you.
It's just a Nate Diaz fight.
Well this isn't a title shot,
I'm saying at least.
It's like,
well,
you know the whole story behind it,
there was a fallout Hofeld dos Anjos is the lightweight champion was supposed to
be fighting Conor McGregor.
He breaks his foot 11 days before the fight.
Nate Diaz takes the fight at the drop of a hat.
No training whatsoever.
I mean fucking none.
They hadn't done anything.
He was at the store.
Yeah,
he was hanging,
hanging out and uh,
Nate,
you know,
posted pictures afterwards of him drinking Tequila and hanging out in Mexico
eating tacos and shit.
So he was just having a car nine bitch.
He's just living his life.
Right.
But he's in such good shape that he can get away with that because he does so
much triathlon training.
He's constantly biking and swimming and running.
He entered into a bunch of triathlons.
He's in very good shape and so he was able to pull it off cause his cardio base
was so good and just,
he's a fucking damn good fighter.
He's a damn good fighter.
And he signed too.
And he's fought legitimately at one 70 twice.
He lost,
he lost a stun gun,
Kim.
And he also lost a Roy McDonald at one 70 these are the legitimate one.
Seventies and Roy being one of the best ones.
The world.
Yeah,
he got ragdolled a little bit by Rory,
but you know that was a wake up call for him.
He went back to one 55 and at one 55 in his last fight against Michael Johnson,
he put on probably the best performance up to the Conor McGregor fight,
the best performance of his career.
He was funny sensation.
When I view Nate Diaz,
I view,
I think of him as a 50 fiver.
He,
that's what he usually competes at.
But for this fight,
like he didn't want to have to cut weight.
It's only 11 days out and he's a little heavy.
So he says,
look,
let's make it one 70 they both agree.
Nate Wade,
one 69 Konner weighed one 68 or maybe vice versa.
I think that's it though.
So I mean they're basically the same size or they fight at one.
Well they fought at one 70 what do you mean when,
when Nate said I'll fight it once every,
where was he walking up?
Probably a little heavier than that.
He probably died it and worked out real hard for seven or eight days of the 11
carpet honors class.
Koppel.
No,
Connor didn't have to cut anything.
I mean,
if he cut anything,
it probably a couple pounds,
which is not,
not not a biggest thing that happens.
One 70 but there's not even 10 pounds different.
So the same way,
like when they got into the octagon,
I guarantee you they're within a pound or two of each other.
Okay.
But Nate is longer and taller and he's a very good boxer.
Like Nate's bars on a regular basis with Andre Ward,
who was one of the best pound for pound,
if not the best pound for pound box or in the world.
Now that Floyd Mayweather,
so quote unquote retired.
Andre Ward is a mother fucker and he just fought this Saturday night on HBO and
I just watched it the other day.
Um,
on a DVR.
It's fucking amazing.
He's so good,
dude.
He's such a,
he's just nasty and he's now he's fighting at one 75 he's gonna fight surge Jay
Sergey Kovalev who's like the best one,
75 are in the world.
So he fought so neat spars with that guy and a day on a regular basis like their
friends.
And you know Nate also spars his brother Nick cause one of the best strikers in
the UFC.
Definitely one of the best boxers.
You know,
he's a very good boxer.
And,
and he also spars with Joe Schilling all the time.
Who is a glory world champion kickboxing world champion.
He's a motherfucker man.
So native sparring with like high level world class striker is like legitimate.
Andre Ward,
Joe Shelley,
two world champions in two d respective disciplines.
So He's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
I just think that people,
he sees him swearing and stick it up his double fingers and they don't realize
all that.
Put all that shit aside and observe his movements,
observe his movements in a fight like in the Michael Johnson fight in the,
uh,
the gummy fight in the markets.
Dave,
his fight in the gray Maynard fight.
Observe his movements.
He's a motherfucker dude.
When he tees off on you,
he comes at you like a snake.
He's got long ass on the most connections of all time where it's like 80% of his
strucks hit strikes hit in the first round.
He Lit Donald Up.
Yeah.
It was like,
what the fuck?
He nothing missed.
He let Donald Up.
He fucked Donald up in that first round.
Donald Donald Donald started coming back with leg kicks.
The only guy who's ever really successfully like put him away in the UFC was
Josh Thompson and Josh Thompson is one of the most underrated guys.
He's,
he's Josh Thompson.
When he was at his best left to go over strike force and a lot of people missed
out on some of the fucking wars that he had over there.
And the Gilbert Melendez fights over there and he went through,
you know,
a lot of wear and tear on you.
But like skill for skill.
Josh Thompson is a motherfucker but he's now,
he's like 36 time just starts to get everybody but at his best.
And I think that like his last fight with Nate Diaz when he had kicked,
I mean he stopped him.
It was one of his best performances ever.
And then they had some losses after that,
but it can't,
it's like it's hard to stay healthy and get through a camp when you're 36 years
old.
When those guys get to the late thirties things start to get,
so he has one loss.
But the loss in my opinion,
I mean one stoppage loss,
but the loss to Thompson is like,
well he's one of the most underrated guys.
So it's like solid loss.
Fuck yeah,
it doesn't get,
doesn't get looked at as solid as it should be.
I think Thompson at its best is he's a motherfucker.
So if,
okay,
so let's say he's a natural one 70,
or let's say he wants to fight the Conor,
he's not,
he just wants to fight this fight at one 70 and prove his point that he could
win point to fight exactly the way they did it before and to come in and fight
in.
This is what happened.
If they're going to do that in the meantime there's lit Frankie and Aldo fight
for a title.
I agree.
How long are you gonna vacate the belt that you haven't defended once Max
Holloway should be in the mix as well?
You know,
I think they also offered,
although a shot at Mcgregor and he didn't take it,
uh,
it could it be a Brazilian thing,
if you know what I mean.
Oh,
what is that?
And steroids,
like you made the injection heroin,
they'll do that.
They still do that,
but for sure it,
uh,
I would say it was more like he's just an unprepared and out of shape and they
want to get knocked out again.
I mean,
the guy just knocked him out with why fucking punch a couple of months ago.
I remember,
but I mean,
he's like,
give me that rematch because it can be imagined.
No,
see,
he didn't know that Connor was going to get worked.
When of got worked by Nate Diaz.
It changed the whole game.
It's like,
oh,
I can change.
Everything changed,
man.
Everything changed in everyone's approach to him.
When you watch a guy get beat up and strangled like that,
you gotta pee again.
Go ahead and do it.
Go ahead.
Do it.
Talking about this.
Don't worry about it man.
But my point is for the folks listing,
when you watch a guy get beat up,
like Conor got beat up against Nate and he shoots for a take down and then it
gets taken down naked on top of them,
beats him up and then chokes him a taps real quick.
Like Nate just dominated them.
Once it got to the ground,
he was already hurt.
When it got to the ground,
then everybody goes,
hmm,
okay.
Could Hofeld dos Anjos do this?
Could.
And for a guy like Conor,
I think one of the reasons why he wants his fight back is to prove that he
fucked up,
that he tried to take Nate out with big power bombs.
He gassed out,
he got tired and then Nate boxed him up in the second round.
Nate start tagging him,
had him hurt and had them shoot for takedown.
So a guy like Conor,
you don't get to be that good.
You don't get to be that far.
You don't get to be that successful.
You don't get to knock out all though with one punch at beat the fuck out of
[inaudible] in the first round,
like you called it and beat the shit out of Seaver and stopped Chad Mendez when
you wanted to bet millions of dollars on it.
I mean,
he's a legit 100% motherfucker,
but the game does not care about personalities.
The game does not care about confidence to interaction of fists and face and
chokes and next and kicks and bodies.
It does not care about anything other than what works.
So like when you see it,
a loss like a Rhonda Rousey getting knocked the fuck out by Holly Holm,
it does not mean that Ronda Rousey sucks.
It does not mean that Holly Holm is the greatest ever.
It just means that the game doesn't give a fuck who you are.
It doesn't care.
You want to charge face first at a counter striker and she clips you with that
first punch.
Your are ready at CEC or already at check,
you got rocked like the first punch and then you're getting beat up for four and
a half minutes after that and then the second round comes around.
You don't even know where the fuck you are.
Your ears are going.
That's it.
You can't see your fucking eyes are blurry.
It must be so weird.
Terrifying.
That's what I love about UFC as opposed to boxing.
Nobody goes 29 to no,
no.
I mean if you go six in a row,
that's like,
wow.
That's why John Jones,
it's so spooky.
Yeah.
Nobody's beating Jon Jones.
Jon Jones.
Jon Jones has one loss and it's a disqualification.
It's Matt Hamill and where he was caressing him.
Yeah.
On top of them.
And it was a,
it's a dumb rule.
It's like a 12 to six elbows from on a clock face.
If you drop an elbow down from 12 to six,
the people that made the rules thought that that's somehow or another,
it was dangerous.
It's no different than any other kind of elbows.
It's just,
yeah,
it's a stupid rule.
It's a rule that they put in place because the people that were on the
commission,
this is coming from big John McCarthy himself.
The people that were on the commission at the time,
they,
um,
they thought that if you dropped a 12 to six elbow,
like those ESPN karate shows,
he could break bricks and shit.
You could kill somebody.
So they,
uh,
they made it illegal.
Meanwhile,
it's not even 12 to six.
It's like one to seven.
It's stupid.
He really,
I could fight again.
It's really almost never 12 to six.
It's always at a slight angle,
but either way it's fucking dumb.
It's a dumb rule.
It doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
Um,
by the way,
we have Nate Diaz calling indoors sports podcast.
Punchdrunk sports id really well fake Nick Diaz.
Nate Diaz fake.
They always call.
I'm glad you had to fake.
How good are they?
The fake ones.
Yeah.
Amazing.
Really.
All the accents are great.
And they talked about two oh nine somewhat.
They're always talking about they're going pontoon boat shopping.
Where are you?
Come on.
Got It here.
I'm mad.
They're great.
It's Danish.
No,
Neil.
And they're so fucking good at it.
For a while they were dating Ronda Rousey and GSP was all upset about it because
he wanted to date Ronda Rousey and they,
they catfished him and buried him and buried him in a,
uh,
on a,
a refrigerator box and the desert.
He got out.
And now GSP is addicted to kitty litter pick.
Could you let her computers break talking to the aliens all the time?
They told me I missed the 2:00 AM two minutes,
my life.
That's hilarious.
I've got to hit,
is that on,
on youtube anywhere?
Uh,
no.
Not Youtube but punchdrunk sports.com I think he'd get clips.
The daily motion was,
I think they're all in daily motion,
Dave.
Any of that stuff.
Yeah.
We got to click that Shit and put it on mute.
Why don't you have clips?
I just don't like,
yeah.
I mean there's no,
I can't give you a good reason that this is the reason why I think the rematches
is huge.
This is why you have to do it.
Okay.
First of all,
because Conor Mcgregor,
up until that fight is one of the most spectacular fighters ever tag people were
talking about him.
Yeah.
Just the spectacle in that sense of spectacular.
The guy gets on stage and screams the lands and the crowd goes nuts in the Irish
flags.
Right.
Galvanized the nation.
And I don't even know what galvanize
it means.
Like a coating when you get nail so they don't rust.
Okay.
Um,
he's spectacular.
Right.
And his results inside the Ark gut other than Nate Diaz fight,
had incredibly dramatic calling.
Exactly.
Second,
second round,
I'll kill him with an uppercut and knock him out.
And then it's like,
what?
But when a guy like Nate Diaz beat you,
beat you,
the way he beat you,
the bright thing to do is to have a rematch.
And this why?
Because the rematch is where the big money's at.
The Murray match with Nate Diaz is God damn scrooge.
Mcduck gigantic die.
Huge.
2 million plus paper view of eyes.
It's still on the table.
If it goes,
let's just say it goes to 45 then maybe 55 again,
there's always going to be like,
well,
I mean they DSL pitcher,
you know.
Exactly.
Not only that,
but here's the other problem.
What Frankie might beat him.
Sure.
Everyone Holloway.
Max Holloway might beat him in a rematch.
Who knows?
Yeah.
Jose Aldo might beat them now.
Now that Joseph especially Jolen we all know
Josie Aldo.
Yeah,
it comes in real healthy.
You know what I'm saying?
If he
chose a,
although he is a fucking nine year undefeated all time,
great fighter who got clipped with one big punch.
So what if Aldo fights like in a similar way to how Misha Tate fought.
Holly Holm takes his time.
Where's that motherfucker out?
And like round two or three and just stays on the outside and leg kicks the shit
out of him if all don't just choose just to have,
I mean all it was so mad.
He tried to take his head off with a left hook and he got clipped.
He would load it up and he got clipped.
But what if he doesn't do that?
What if he goes in there and play slow on the outside?
Starts kicking his legs?
What if he initiates a clinch?
Cause let me tell you something about all those Jujitsu.
It's fucking world class like you watch or Aldo versus Mike Brown in the UFC or
the WC rather when he wanted to Walter,
they'll featherweight title can't get anything.
Right.
When he won the featherweight title to it,
he takes his back like a fucking world champion and smashes him.
So a cyborgs in the UFC now too.
That's amazing.
I just heard that from you.
We're open pool.
You know?
Finally,
finally.
Yeah.
At one 41 40 yeah.
The pro rada thoughts finds it.
35 yes.
And she's going to fight Leslie Smith who fights at one 35 she's,
it's the girl at her ear exploded or year got torn off by Jessica.
I,
what's the problem?
Uh,
well it's not a problem,
but it's a one 40 pound weight class instead of a one 45 that's the one 45 is
what she's champion of in Invicta.
And I think the idea is that they worry that they don't have enough 145 pound
talent.
I think they didn't have enough hunter [inaudible] I know for sure that it
didn't have 115 pound talent.
Some of the third bout to get somebody a third rematch in five years.
Like,
come on man.
But you mean me?
She taped it was like you don't have a deep enough way class if that's what you
keep doing.
Well,
sort of,
but I mean that's the same problem they're going to have right now at
welterweight.
The same problem you're talking about at one 45 which has a lot of talent.
There's a lot of talented one 45 in men's.
So this is what I think.
I think,
uh,
first of all,
she's fucking terrifying.
I want to talk about like one of the scariest strikers in MMA,
cyborgs.
Terrifying.
And Tony and I got in trouble because we,
uh,
said some inappropriate jokes about what would a roast w be like with her.
All jokes aside,
even before that I had tweeted that a,
I would love to see her in the UFC for sure.
She's name,
she's a monster.
And I think also we shouldn't have double standards as far as who takes
performance enhancing drugs,
whether it's for men or for women,
like,
oh,
they,
like things are kind of is I think the way people look at it,
what a woman is taking testosterone versus a man taking testosterone because
it's already part of your body.
Yeah.
But you know,
honestly,
like some of the things that men have been caught with have been pretty
unnatural as well.
Like super human levels of testosterone that don't even exist in medical books,
you know?
So it's,
you could argue that it's dangerous because a woman does change her anatomy.
Whatever they're testing are now.
Yeah.
But your anatomy changes.
Oh,
right.
But you have to make a weight class.
It's,
it's tricky man.
I mean,
it always seen before this Holly Holm thing happened and that's all fishy too.
What's fishy?
Rhonda won't take a fight,
won't take a fight against Holly Holm,
and then it's suddenly like Misha Tate.
When's like,
I'm ready to fight now.
It's like,
oh no.
She's not necessarily ready to fight now.
No,
she,
she's not,
she can't fight until like November.
She is,
she's gotten movie obligations.
They got moved around.
See that's bad right there,
right when the movies get in the way.
Yeah.
Of your fights.
Like you gotta pick one or the other.
So in between,
yeah,
I,
as soon as my fights over,
I can do your movie for the next three months and then I got her back to
training.
It's gotta be hard though when you're a,
you know,
a super celebrity and you're getting all this love and everybody wants to put
you in all these different things.
It's gotta be hard to say no to certain things obviously.
But the same shit happens.
A female comics.
Yeah.
But it's way worse with a fighter because of fighter has to be physically tuned
up to go in to do battle and get kicked in the fucking,
yeah.
It's way worse.
A fighter.
It's just similar where it's like you're not concentrating on the thing that got
you there.
So the thing that got you there is now suffering.
Yeah.
Maybe you don't care anymore.
Maybe you just want to do movies.
Okay.